I want to start with your level of
optimism here that we're gonna see some
sort of big infrastructure spending a
package how optimistic are you mr. Smith
that that's going to happen well I hope
that they're going to fund it and get
going with it our infrastructure is
badly in need of being updated
modernized repaired and expanded and
that's what we were talking about today
in the panel that I participated on at
the House Transportation and
Infrastructure Committee here in
Washington do you think that we have a
problem with our definition of
infrastructure we hear the president
talk about roads and bridges trains and
planes it is more widely construed than
that do you think we need a more
expansive definition of what
infrastructure is in the year 2017 well
I think to some degree David that's been
one of the problems everybody wants to
define the infrastructure to fit what
they'd like to do locally whether it's a
bike path or a fast train or
what-have-you and in our mind the
infrastructure that's most important is
that that supports the common good and
the economy of the United States
that's highways that's waterways it's
airports it's the air traffic control
system it's our River navigation
capabilities the container ports and
they all have a common theme to them and
that they are used by commercial
interests and can be and should be
funded by taxes or user fees from the
people that use those systems there will
be people who say that we've seen this
movie before after the financial crisis
we had a big stimulus package there are
people who debate how shovel-ready
shovel-ready projects were what's gonna
be different this time around what's
gonna make it different if we do get a
big spending package well first of all
the stimulus package under the Obama
administration wasn't directed in the
Maine towards projects like I just
listed it was diffused into all kinds of
different places many of them worthy no
doubt about it
firefighters police people policemen
other governmental activities our issue
in the United States transportation and
infrastructure arena is our roadways are
deteriorating because
have it increase the federal gasoline
and diesel tax since 1994
we certainly hadn't expanded them to the
needs of the economy that's much more
popular much greater population today
than we had 20 years ago there 20
interstate highway projects that are in
the queue at the d-o-t they may not be
shovel ready but they're engineered and
with the appropriate funding they could
be built a few people have seen the rise
of e-commerce as closely as you have
there at the helm of FedEx how has that
changed our infrastructure needs the
growth of e-commerce the projections
that will continue to see it grow well
one of the things I talked about today
that's absolutely essential the less
than truckload and ground parcel
industries which are the the bedrock
transportation systems as support
ecommerce have to be improved by
allowing a federal standard of 33-foot
twin-trailers as opposed to the existing
federal standard of 28 feet now 33 s are
authorized in some states we use them in
Florida for instance they're safer they
provide about 18 percent more capacity
they take millions of truck trips off
the road improving safety by reducing
the number of accidents by reducing the
number of trips decreasing congestion
this is something the government doesn't
have to do anything except pass a new
federal standard I might point out in
Mexico by the way that their standard is
twin 40 feet containers so this is
something that that should be done as
quickly as possible by the Congress